Bruce Jenner is on the new cover of
Vanity Fair as her new identity Caitlyn
Jenner yeah this is historic because
Caitlyn's the first woman from that
family to appear on a magazine cover
fully clothed she's actually covered up
and Jason
speaking of Kardashians Kim Kardashian
just announced she's pregnant she's
pregnant again
yeah second child yeah Kim said it's
been a difficult pregnancy she wakes up
in the middle of the night craving
publicity
[Applause]
thank you very much I appreciate that
the British Parliament liked my joke
[Applause]
there's another kind of craving we
thought you were going to say here's a
crazy story kids
a lawyer from Africa a lawyer from
Africa wants to marry Malia Obama in
exchange for goats sheep and cows yeah
in response President Obama said don't
be ridiculous my daughter isn't marrying
a lawyer anybody see the movie san
andreas you see that movie man I'm
talking to the right crowd it's like the
number one movie in the country no and I
get the chess team here tonight
is this San Andreas because Dungeons and
Dragons night here at the show oh yeah
now I got your attention
I put a spell on thee it's a big deal
the big movie over the weekend was san
andreas number-one movie it's a movie
about a devastating earthquake that hits
California yeah thanks to the success of
that movie it's gonna be followed up by
the even more exciting movie droughts
[Applause]
it's a twenty two hour movie of me not
watering my lawn yeah people just
watching it's like Dwayne the rock
Johnson watching his his lawn brown out
a new study just came out a new study
says record record numbers of college
students from China are getting expelled
from the United States colleges for
cheating their cheating here yeah great
so now Chinese students to finally beat
Americans at the last thing we were
number one in we were good
[Applause]
it's true yeah
worldwide sports scandal unfolding FIFA
isn't it called FIFA it is FIFA yeah I
love that I love that named FIFA hard to
take them seriously with that name come
here FIFA you don't know you don't want
FIFA matter yeah
no FIFA a huge story last week massive
corruption in international soccer
massive scandal
yeah the first clue was when a soccer
team scored a suspiciously high three
goals in one game that's how they knew
something was up three gold we're like
that was exciting for a second
something's wrong
oh you guys like soccer - soccer in
chess free hey thanks for watching be
sure to click subscribe to see even more
great Conan clips you may now return to
your pirated movies and creepy Japanese
pornography